best TV show of the year it's a blessing  it's great it's crazy  oh hello Daka we dig into to the lives  of the characters in it it's very  emotional it's a lot it's a lot more  darker you know like last year was you  know we have to miss a kid this year is  like oh I I can't even say anything so  I'm not gonna go there no yeah no  spoilers did I get anything out of I'm  sorry  you gotta raise the bar a little bit you  know but you learn more about each  character a lot more like that doesn't  not only does a dive into the lore and  history of the show itself and  everything but it dives into the history  and personalities of each character  which I'm really excited for everyone to  see and rumor has it  we might get a cameo from barb in season  2 I hope there will be justice for bar  [Music]